In our daily routine, we eat pain killers very often.
If we have a headache, we eat pain killers. If we have
pain in our body, we eat pain killers
like paracetamol. We eat easily.
But what will happen if we eat too much pain killers?
Then we eat pain killers.  What does
prostate glanding do in our body? It
decreases its secretion of chemicals,
due to which what will happen is that our blood
vessels will not be able to supply blood properly.
Our kidneys will
not be able to filter blood properly. If
we talk about the stomach,  If we do this then the HCA present here
increases in the digestive juice due to which
peptic ulcers occur.
If we talk about females then
specifically the prostate gland is
required for child birth as well as for menstrual cycle.
Due to its deficiency, they too will become
painful, so we should eat
less of your pain killer.